this is your home and this is you or
maybe this is you don't bring it and
this is your new home
Hillsdale College these next four years
will be filled with new people new ideas
and plenty of new challenges but don't
worry you won't be alone welcome to the
fourth floor of central hall where Rita
Conrad and Carolyn Milligan are ready to
greet you and this is the Dean team an
experienced an equipped group of Dean's
who are passionate about supporting you
in every aspect as you navigate your
college experience they partner with
student services across campus including
academic services the Student Activities
Board the health center and the Career
Services office this is Dean Phillip VP
of Student Affairs and Dean of women she
graduated from Hillsdale in 1982 and
started coaching track and cross-country
for the college that year now she uses
that coaching experience to mentor the
young woman of Hillsdale this is Miss
Dell associate dean of women
she graduated from Hillsdale in 2006
since graduating she's traveled to 26
countries she was an RA in an art major
and she's applied her creativity to make
the dorms across campus look and feel
like home this is Dean Pete Dean of men
he graduated from Hillsdale in 1996 in
college he was head RA and Simpson dorm
and played a lot of sports he has eight
kids and is a deacon at his church
some nights he's at home with the kids
and other nights he's making a
cheeseburger run with the guys from
Simpson this is chief Rogers associate
dean of men you can just call him chief
that was his rank in the US Navy and the
name kind of stuck chief loves talking
about big questions and at some point
he'll probably tell you to focus less on
GPA and more on g.od so the next time
you're feeling overwhelmed by academics
or you're just not sure what you want to
do with your life you know where to
start
[Music]
you